je suis un pigeon et j'ai été vulgarisé
tout a commencé avec cette vidéo qui
dévoilait notre suprématie sur l'espèce
humaine
avant on nous traitait d'abrutis de rats
volants on nous jetait les coups de
pieds nous donner le coup de pied ce
serait nous dire s'il était lobé mais
depuis depuis les gens ont pris
conscience de notre potentiel
intellectuel
j'en ai des frères qui sont morts au
champ d'honneur enfermées dans des
boîtes à faire des acrobaties sous le
regard médusé des blouses blanches trier
des formes classes et des nombreux bars
ordre croissant
j'ai oublié la suite quand je dis
souvent c'est une façon parc n'empêche
que ça serait pas la mort la plus
géniale est le mieux ça serait de mourir
de rire
sans blague hein c'est déjà arrivé bon
c'est hyper rare ok mais dans
l'antiquité à un philosophe grec qui
s'appelle crise id de soles il a fait
boire du vin en had et il a regardé
manger des filles le mais ça l'a
tellement fait rire qu'ils ont dû morts
d'un autre côté la bourrique doux et
s'en sort bien parce que vu comme les
grecs étaient portés sur la chose à
l'époque le bateau fait dégénérer
d'ailleurs c'est avec les animaux les
plus victimes d'agressions sexuelles
aujourd'hui c'est les équidés les ânes
les mulets les chevaux et les jugements
grand pour plus de la moitié des crimes
rapportés aux bêtes
n'empêche que la zoophilie c'est
beaucoup moins rare qu'on pense à
aujourd'hui aux états unis près d'une
personne sur dix consultent des sites
porno au fil en admettant que ce soit la
même chose en france
ça voudrait dire que cette partie de
l'amphi rêve de faire la peau aux
clients que je suis sa voiture je n'en
veux pas je tairai je comprends j'ai
l'oeil vif et la punition au lieu de ça
dépend je suis pas jaloux quoique j'en
ai aussi dans la cervelle j'ai un sens
de l'orientation de ouf
quand je vois mon reflet dans un miroir
je me reprenne et moi même ça voudrait
dire que j'ai conscience de moi prenez
genre un chien vous verrez vos bébés
sans sont capables et c'est à tous
je vais apprendre des tours on m'a
appris à distinguer la musique de chopin
et celle de stravinsky à faire la
différence entre une toile de matisse et
de braque le peintre un patch
je précise que ce oui figurez vous qu'on
est même meilleur que vous à certains
jeux de logique
je sais reconnaître des visages humains
je sais mémoriser des images pendant
plusieurs années
on n'est pas con on n'est pas contre la
cause de cette vidéo vous le savez
maintenant
du coup on peut plus sortir tranquille
dès que je mène pas dehors je me fais
harcelées à coups de sel filles et
d'autocars j'ai fait trois fois la une
de voile à la semaine dernière ça peut
plus durer
mais je laisse la solution je vais
retrouver l'auteur de la vidéo qui a
tout déclenché et je vais faire ce que
nous les pigeons sait faire de mieux lui
faire caca dessus
[Applaudissements]